FINALLY TONIGHT, THERE PEOPLE
WHO TALK THE TALK, SOME EVEN
MAKE A LIVING DOING IT AND I AM
GENERALLY HUMORED BY THEM, THE
ONES WHO THINK THEY KNOW
EVERYTHING.
THEY HAVE NO EXPERIENCE, FRAME
OF REFERENCE BUT STILL ASSUME,
PRESUME AND FANCY THEY KNOW IT
ALL.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> LOOK AT WHAT JEANINE.
OH,  THIS IS OUTRAGEOUS.
I’M LOOKING AT YOU, YOU SHOULD
BE ASHAMED OF YOURSELF, SHE SAID
THESE KIDS ARE LOWER LEVEL OF
HUMAN BEING.
JUDGE JEANINE: A PERFECT EXAMPLE
OF ONE WHO TALKS THE TALK.
I JUST CAME BACK FROM SOUTHWEST
BORDER HAVING INTERVIEWED PEOPLE
ON THE FRONT LINE WHO SAY
CHILDREN ARE BEING TRAPPED BY
THE CARTELS AND FORCED INTO A
LOWER LEVEL OF HUMAN BEING.
THE SHERIFF IN CHARGE OF THE
LARGEST SOUTHWEST INTERNATIONAL
BORDER AREA IN THE U.S. AND ONE
OF THE MOST DANGEROUS CARTEL
OPERATES IN THE COUNTY SAYS
WHAT’S HAPPENING TO THESE
CHILDREN IS MODERN DAY SLAVERY.
CHILDREN ULTIMATELY BECOME
SLAVES TO THE CARTEL.
CONSIDER THIS.
20% OF THE CHILDREN BROUGHT HERE
HAVE NO KNOWN FAMILY IN THE
UNITED STATES.
TRANSNATIONAL CARTEL UPON THEM
PUTTING THEM IN HARMS WAY AND
USE AND ABUSE THE CHILDREN,
PHYSICALLY AND SEXUALLY, EVEN
KEEPING THEM UNDER THE CARTEL
THEM ONCE THEY ARE IN THE UNITED
STATES BECAUSE THEY HAVE NO
FAMILY HERE.
THEY ARE FORCED TO CONTINUE TO
WORK FOR THE CARTEL, WE ARE NOT
EVEN TAKING DNA WHICH FOR THESE
CHILDREN WILL IDENTIFY THEM.
TO ME, THAT’S PLACING IN HIS
VULNERABLE CHILDREN AND THAT THE
ENVIRONMENT, FORCING THEM TO BE
LOWER LEVEL HUMAN THAT ANY
REASONABLE PERSON WOULD
RECOGNIZE AS FOREIGN.
THOSE CHILDREN I SPOKE ABOUT ON
FOX, THE ONES BEING TRAFFICKED,
ABUSED AND BROUGHT ACROSS THE
BORDER WHO THEN BECOME SLAVES TO
SEX TRAFFICKERS.
I KNOW, BELIEVE ME, I KNOW.
I PROSECUTED CASES LIKE THESE ON
BEHALF OF VICTIMS.
MANY OF WHOM DIDN’T SPEAK
ENGLISH AND AFRAID TO SPEAK IN
THEIR NATIVE TONGUE BECAUSE
CARTEL HELP FAMILIES IN THEIR
HOME COUNTRIES UNDER THE THREAT
OF VIOLENCE OR RETRIBUTION.
PROVIDE TRANSLATORS TO HELP
PROTECT THESE VICTIMS.
MY JOY HAS BEEN PROTECTING
CHILDREN MY WHOLE CAREER.
I STARTED ONE OF THE FIRST
CHILD-ABUSE UNITS IN THE NATION,
CHECK YOUR FAVORITE PAPER, THE
NEW YORK TIMES, CHILD-ABUSE WAS
CONSIDERED A SOCIAL ISSUE AND
NOT A CRIME.
I DIDN’T TALK ABOUT IT, I DID IT
IT.
I MADE IT HAPPEN.
TO ME A CHILD CHANGING A
RADIATOR IS NOT A SOCIAL
PROBLEM, A CHILD TOO YOUNG TO
IDENTIFY THE SEXUAL PARTS OF HER
BODY BEING ABUSED IS ENTITLED TO
MORE THAN MEDIATION, SHE’S
ENTITLED TO JUSTICE.
I ALSO STARTED ONE OF THE FIRST
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE HOUSTON UNITS
IN THE NATION FIGHTING TO
PROTECT BATTERED WOMEN AND
CHILDREN FORCED TO LIVE WITH THE
VIOLENCE, SOME OF WHOM ARE
MURDERED IN THAT SAME VIOLENT
HOME.
I DIDN’T JUST TALK THE TALK
ABOUT CHILDREN BEING RAPED OR
BEATEN TO DEATH, I DID SOMETHING
ABOUT IT, I SPENT MY TIME IN
EMERGENCY ROOMS OF VICTIMS,
HOSPITAL ROOMS WITH CHILDREN AND
MORGUES AND HEARTBREAKING
SILENCE.
YOU WANT TO LECTURE ME?
YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT ESCAPING
VIOLENCE?
>> PEOPLE ARE ESCAPING VIOLENCE,
DRUGS, ESCAPING POVERTY AND WITH
CLIMATE CHANGE ON THE HORIZON I
THINK IT’S ON TO GET WORSE.
JUDGE JEANINE: ESCAPING
VIOLENCE?
THAT’S THE WHOLE THING, EVEN THE
SHERIFF SAID IT WAS MODERN DAY
SLAVERY BECAUSE THE CARTELS HOLD
US, ONTO THESE CHILDREN.
USE THINK THEY ARE ESCAPING
DRUGS?
THEY ARE BECOMING MULES FOR THE
CARTEL.
FOR 30 YEARS I HELPED PEOPLE
ESCAPED VIOLENCE AND PUNISHED
THOSE WHO COMMITTED THAT
VIOLENCE, I DIDN’T TALK ABOUT
IT, I DIDN’T PUT MYSELF ON A
CHAIR IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA AND
YAP ABOUT SOMETHING, I
PROSECUTED, CONVICTED, SENTENCED
AND WHEN BOSS WANT STRONG
ENOUGH, I THOUGHT TO CHANGE THE
LAWS AND CREATED TASKFORCES AND
PROVIDED SHELTERS AND SAFE
HAVENS, CONNECTING WITH CHURCHES
AND SOCIAL SERVICES AND MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS SO DON’T
YOU EVER ACCUSE ME BECAUSE
UNLIKE YOU, I DON’T JUST TALK
THE TALK, I HAVE ACTUALLY WALKED
THE WALK, I DID SOMETHING.
I DID SOMETHING.
I ACTUALLY DID SOMETHING SO
INSTEAD OF SITTING ON YOUR BUTT
WITH YOUR FRIENDS, GET DOWN TO
THE BORDER, GO INTO A COURTROOM,
FAMILY COURT, A SHELTER,
VOLUNTEER, HAVE THE COURAGE TO
STEP UP YOUR STAGE AND DO
SOMETHING THAT MATTERS, THAT
MAKES A DIFFERENCE YES, JOY, I